[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du débrief du doc on évoque
aujourd'hui un documentaire qui est
disponible sur le site berthet france
gangnam stress un documentaire consacré
au stress en corée du sud et plus
particulièrement dans la capitale séoul
pour en parler nous sommes avec
christophe godin sociologue enseignant
en sciences politiques à l'université de
séoul bonjour monsieur gaudin merci
d'être avec nous depuis la corée du sud
un pays vous êtes installé depuis 14 ans
maintenant vous allez pouvoir nous
éclairer sur les aspects de ce fléau sud
coréens alors première question vous qui
êtes un habitant de séoul est ce qu'on
peut dire que le stress est palpable
dans cette ville coréenne
oui vous savez ces mêmes les premières
expressions qu'on apprend en fait quand
j'ai commencé à étudier coréen il ya
donc quinze ans déjà les premières
expressions qu'on entend c'est des
expressions du type je vais mourir c'est
difficile comment je vais faire et ainsi
de suite
le c'est vrai que le stress est partout
et en même temps vous savez l'accord est
aussi une culture très théâtral les gens
viennent se plaindre les gens aiment se
mettre en scène et le documentaire est
intéressant pour ça parce qu'on y vont
en même temps la réalité du phénomène et
la façon dont les corps et à anjou on
voit aussi que c'est une culture qui est
qui est très théâtral et de la part
d'une culture asiatique c'est quelque
chose d'assez inattendu je pense pour un
public occidental
je propose justement qu'on rentre dans
le vif du sujet en regardant un premier
extrait il s'agit de femmes de femmes
veuves qui ont donc perdu leur mari qui
s'est suicidé après un trop plein de
stress notamment au travail propose de
regarder cet extrait
les suicides provoqués par le stress au
travail ne sont qu'une partie du
problème
nous nous rendons auprès d'un groupe de
soutien pour les femmes dont les maris
sont morts de surmenage
elles ont préféré rester anonyme pour ne
pas avoir de problème quant à
l'obtention de compensation de la part
des entreprises pour lesquelles leur
mari travaillait
ici j'ai dessiné mon mari avec thales
cela ne veut pas dire qu'il buvait et
fumait beaucoup cette année
cela montre que même s'ils vivent en
société il était toujours seul je veux
dire qu'il était tout seul face à ses
problèmes psy comme tel c'est la chose
la plus importante dont je me souviens
ça a été une moitié de vie à mai et on
dit les coups il préférait aller boire
ou fumer
plutôt que de me parler de ses soucis et
d'essayer de sourire à quai ou sera
victime
l'alcool est l'un des moyens les plus
populaires d'évacuer le stress célébrer
la fin de semaine de travail avec ses
collègues est presque devenue une
tradition en corée du sud
michelot et on peut se dire que voir et
relaxant glace est très commun internet
c'est comme la consommation de plats
épicés et shutter les gens tu penses tu
évacue le stress mais la consommation
prolongée d'alcool et nuisibles en mer
conjuguer la nourriture épicée
c'est comme un analgésique
alors on voit dans cet extrait qu'une
des façons pour les sud coréens de de se
débarrasser du stress accumulé pendant
toute la semaine c'est de boire de
l'alcool est ce que vous avez un regard
sur 7 sur cet aspect là de la vie
culturelle d'une sud coréenne
ouais si vous aviez été encore et je
pense vous poseriez même pas la question
parce que les coréens boire énormément
au point que ces mêmes
vous savez quand vous voyagez en asie
c'est la première chose qu'on vous dit
quand vous dites que vous venez de corée
c'est là bas qu'est ce que les gens
boivent ya un désir d'être ensemble qui
est vraiment très propre à lester corps
et une chaleur humaine qui est vraiment
quelque chose de palpable
une excitation consent dans le cinéma
coréen consent dans la musique qu'au
real quelque chose de très et de traits
frénétique comme ça et en même temps
justement ce qui se passe c'est le fait
que si vous avez une société qui était à
la base très communautaire et c'est la
rupture de ses liens communautaires qui
abandonne les gens dans une solitude et
cette solitude se traduit dans un taux
de suicides qui explose parce que ce qui
est important c'est le fait que ce taux
de suicide
il est important mais il a quadruplé
depuis le début des années 80 donc c'est
un phénomène qui est très important et
qui est récent c'est à dire que ce qui
se passe si vous avez une société où les
gens boivent où les gens font la fête
mais inversement si vous voulez ces
liens sont tellement importants que
lorsqu'il se rompe et il donne une
impression de solitude qui est bien plus
forte que celle qu on éprouverait en
occident une aussi au japon c'est à dire
que dans des sociétés beaucoup moins
communautaire que l'accord est donc on
voit dans l'extrait que le travail n'est
pas la seule raison qui pousse les
coréens au suicide mais malgré tout il
ya une force 13 qui est née sur le lieu
de travail avec un taux de travail
hebdomadaire notamment qui est très
important même s'il a été réduit ces
dernières années
oui alors ça par contre c'est ce qu'il
faut un petit peu nuancé parce que c'est
vrai que le nombre d'heures de travail
est très important mais si vous regardez
la productivité par habitant elle et
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
bien plus importante en france ton corps
et c'est à dire qu'en france quand vous
travaillez 35 heures par semaine
les coréens 35 ou 40 les coréens trouve
ça très dur parce que quand vous
travaillez
on attend de vous que vous ne fassiez
que travailler tandis que dans ses 68
eur il ya énormément d'heures ou où les
gens papote où les gens boivent du café
c'est presque quelque chose
d'institutionnaliser en fait et coréens
sont très très très très peu chez eux
ils vivent hors de chez eux ils mangent
hors de chez eux
alors c'est vrai qu'à côté de ça vous
avez vous avez raison de le dire
énormément de stress au travail mais
c'est pas seulement une question
d'heures de travail
c'est le fait que comme on passe sa vie
au travail pas seulement à travailler
mais à socialiser
c'est très difficile de faire de la
paire d'échasses et 2 et de faire une
coupure
c'est très difficile de s'arrêter la
cité coréenne et une société excitante à
tous les sens du terme au bon sens du
terme au mauvais sens du terme
il ne s'était frénétique une société où
qui ne s'arrête jamais et quand pour une
raison pour une autre vous n'arrivez
plus à suivre où vous perdez votre
travail ou quelque chose comme ça bien
tout d'un coup effectivement c'est
quelque chose de très difficile à lire
bien plus encore qu'en occident et une
scène aussi qui est assez
impressionnante dans le documentaire
c'est d'ailleurs une des premières
scènes de ce documentaire c'est lorsque
on suit des secouristes qui viennent
donc en aide à des personnes qui sont en
état de stress intense
on voit qu'il ya un attaché de presse
allemand qui interrompt le l'interview
pour demander peut-être que les
questions ne portent pas sur différentes
thématiques notamment celle du suicide
est ce que ça veut dire que le sujet est
encore tabou aujourd'hui en corée du sud
non annoncé c'est probablement dans le
documentaire la face au mont joli du
mois c'est plutôt quelque chose c'est
par peur de gêner très probablement
d'exposer les personnes qui étaient en
train d'être recouru ainsi de suite au
contraire observé les coréens sont très
conscients du problème et c'est quelque
chose qui est débattue en permanence
dans l'est des balles dans l'est dans
les médias coréens
vous avez par exemple il ya deux ans une
star de la pop le chanteur est
championne qui s'était suicidé et la
suite de ça il ya eu six mois de débats
ininterrompue normes et les gens voient
qu'il ya un problème mais il sent
quelque sorte
accro à cette excitation et ils savent
pas s'arrêter c'est une excitation qui
est qui cultivé depuis l'enfance si je
vous raconte une anecdote qui est tout
bête
par exemple quand vous avez un petit qui
attend le l'ascenseur avec sa mère tout
le temps vous verrez le petit en train
de compter un bourg 7 6 5 et ainsi de
suite
et quand l'ascenseur s'arrête se tourner
vers sa mère et lui dit à maman que je
le fais bien et habile répondent oui mon
chéri maman est très contente depuis
depuis le plus jeune âge vous avez 7
ce désir de faire bien et de faire
plaisir
cette incapacité à dire non en fait
c'est un problème de ne pas pouvoir
s'arrêter
les gens voient qu'il ya un problème
mais ça va faire autrement
est ce que vous diriez que ce stress et
ce taux de suicide est entre guillemets
une contrepartie un dommage collatéral à
l'excellence à la sud coréenne avec
cette volonté d'avoir toujours de très
bons résultats dans tous les secteurs
en un sens oui
après si vous regardez les taux de
suicide du japon et de la chine
c'est une société qui sont tout aussi
compétitif que la corée mais le taux de
suicide est beaucoup plus bas par
exemple le taux de la corée c'est
presque le double du japon et le triple
de la chine
donc en effet il ya l'effet du stress ça
c'est indéniable mais il ya quelque
chose en plus c'est à dire c'est l'effet
de la solitude dans une société où les
gens avaient vraiment l'habitude d'être
ensemble
si vous vous souvenez par exemple de ces
de ces femmes donc dans les maris se
sont suicidés ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que l'heure
une réaction pour faire face au chagrin
justement ces deux se mettre ensemble de
dessiner en groupe
la parole ne circule pas vraiment dans
un tête à tête avec un psychanalyste par
exemple tout de suite parce que vous
allez être gêné et c'est ça aussi la
réaction du la réaction du secouriste
dont vous parlais tout à l'heure
surtout devant des médias étrangers en
fait il n'a pas voulu gêner la personne
l'exposé à un regard trop étranger en
revanche quand vous avez des gens qui
sont tout un tous ensemble surtout
justement avec l'alcool puisque l'alcool
sert à ça et alcool sarah briser la
carapace individuel la la parole circule
et là les gens commencent à vider leur
sac à dire qu'ils ont sur le coeur
si vous regardez même dans le détail le
taux de réussite de l'accord et vous
allez voir que le taux de suicide
explose chez les gens qui divorcent chez
les gens qui perdent leur travail chez
les gens qui sont à la retraite et tout
particulièrement les hommes parce que
ces temps consacré à leur travail
presque uniquement et liens familiaux
pour eux sont beaucoup plus fragiles
dont vous voyez dans tous les cas c'est
des gens qui se retrouvent seules parce
que les liens se coupent du jour au
lendemain il ya vraiment je ne sais pas
si en france on le sent mais par exemple
quand vous regardez ce film parasites
qui ait eu l'oscar du meilleur film l'an
dernier on la voit cette excitation
cette joie de vivre même qui à séoul
cette joie de vivre presque isle
résonnaient et qu'on sent tout de suite
quand on arrive est justement une sorte
de pression sociale avec une forme de
culture de la comparaison c'est à dire
que vous disais très bien la solitude et
peut-être qui conduit le plus en réalité
au suicide et que effectivement
lorsqu'on a des accidents de la vie et
que peut-être sa réputation doit être
entachée c'est là aussi on peut
commettre l'irréparable
c'est ça d'un point de vue occidental
on pourrait penser qu'il ya une une
contradiction entre des sociétés qui
sont très compétitives
des sociétés qui sont très sûrs et très
solidaire d'une solidarité encore et
dont on n'a pas idée c'est des gens
vraiment sur qui on peut compter
mais ya pas de ya aucune comparaison
dans le sens où justement comme société
commune auteur d'un côté vous allez vous
comparez sans cesse avec d autres ce qui
fait qu'il a comparé la compétition
capitaliste qui existe partout
vous savez en idéogrammes la compétition
c'est la guerre des talents donc c'est
quelque chose de très intenses puisque
vous comparez infiniment plus cette
compétition va être plus violente et en
même temps c'est aussi une société où on
peut compter sur les autres il ya une
discipline collective très forte et on
l'a vu très bien avec le court aux
navires us et c'est aussi décidé qu'ils
sont très sûrs pour cette même raison
parce qu'il ya respect des autres le
respect de ces d'un père du tout en
corée du sud contrairement à beaucoup de
sociétés occidentales christophe godin
va marquer une courte pause on revient
dans quelques instants pour continuer de
débriefer ce documentaire gangnam stress
de retour dans le débrief du dock
consacrée aujourd'hui à ganges dame
stress un documentaire qui suit les
suicides notamment en corée du sud dans
la capitale à séoul on est avec
christophe godin sociologue enseignant
en sciences politiques à l'université de
séoul
installé dans le pays depuis plus de 14
ans va parler dans quelques instants
des solutions qui sont tentés par
certains coréens puis par aussi l'impact
de la pandémie sur ce fléau
d'abord je propose de regarder un
extrait on parlait de la solitude en
corée qui est combattu par les habitants
et regarder quand ils vont au restaurant
c'est aussi pour combattre le stress
park nous a montré l'un des moyens les
plus populaires et simple de lutter
contre le stress en corée nous avons
goûté un prêt spécifique lequel big jim
je me prépare à lancer une nouvelle
émission
donc j'ai eu beaucoup de rendez vous
dernièrement et je suis tout en sous
stress j'ai donc décidé de dîner épicé
ce soir avec mes amis des propos
beaucoup de jeunes mangent de la
nourriture épicée pour évacuer comme le
stress la nourriture épicée contient des
endorphines qui donne tout cargo
tout le monde sait que cela remonte le
moral entier les études réalisées sur
des animaux montrent qu'un repas épicé
est source de bonne humeur car il va lui
même d'autres ni le roi ni
[Musique]
non
à
on
[Musique]
ça
quand on voit cet extrait on ne nie pas
évidemment que les épices peuvent avoir
un effet sur le stress mais on comprend
en fait que c'est le fait de se réunir
qui permet pour ces jeunes sud coréens
de combattre ce stress oui non mais ça
me faisait rire parce que c'est vraiment
là pour le coup c'est vraiment du bon
travail parce que le reportage montre
bien le genre d'ambiance qui atteint et
les coréens fait savoir qu'ils aient une
cuisine qui est très épicé en gros là où
dans la cuisine occidentale en salles
dans la cuisine coréenne mon épices ce
qui la rend un vrai cauchemar à manger
au début si on n'a pas si on n'a pas
l'habitude mais il ya vraiment quelque
chose comme ça les coréens aime les
alcools forts
il aime les aime les épices il aime tout
ce qui est fort il aime la musique comme
vous savez la musique
comment dirais-je bruyante il est nous
tous qui est rapide
10e tout ce qui est épicé il aime tout
ce qui va vite et ça d'ailleurs
là on l'entend recouvert par la part la
traduction mais l'expression qu'il
emploie en coréen c'est justement cela
ces expulsés le stress et cette idée que
quand vous quand vous mangez épicé vous
transpirez et d'une certaine manière ça
vous fait évacuer le stress de la même
manière il ya des saunas partout dans la
ville et les coréens vont aussi au sauna
pour ça pendant on les voit allongé des
heures mais dans des dents des dents de
température incroyable pour ce faire
suivre au maximum alors quand on voit
ces images cette scène au restaurant ne
peut pas s'empêcher d'imaginer l'impact
qu'a pu avoir la pandémie locaux vides
19 sur le mode de vie des des sud
coréens on a quelques chiffres pour
l'instant qui ne sont pas encore tout à
fait établi sur la hausse du taux de
suicide en corée du sud par rapport à
cette pandémie
quel impact a eu selon vous ce
cette maladie sur sur les habitants et
sur le stress donc là vous l'avez vous
l'avait bien dit c'est là qu'on voit le
lien la pandémie a été géré en corée
vraiment demain m vous savez qu'il ya eu
qu'un effet très peu de morts
extrêmement peu de mort si vous comparez
le nombre de morts par rapport par
rapport la plupart des grands pays
occidentaux
c'est un rapport de 1 50 ou 1 cents est
ce qu'on ne sait pas si en occident
c'est qu'en corée il n'y a pas eu de
confinement les restaurants sont restés
ouverts parce que tout le monde
presque tout le temps par contre c'est
vrai qu'ils ferment à 9 heures ou à 10
heures suivant la situation sanitaire et
que théoriquement on peut se réunir
seulement par table et de quatre et ce
qui se passe c'est que justement ces
grands rassemblements qui servent aux
gens à créer du lien en effet ces
rassemblements n'ont plus cours et puis
continuer à aller au restaurant tout le
temps parce que les coréens ont cette
habitude de manger dehors beaucoup plus
que chez eux
mais comme vous l'avez dit le fait que
ces grands beuvry nenê plus lieu
ça se traduit très directement dans une
augmentation au taux de suicide
là le lien le lien et lien est direct de
la même manière pardon mais vous savez à
l'université et cette tradition de
granby cannes de devrient mais qui sont
des choses inimaginables parce que j'ai
jamais vue en france
mais le fait que évidemment tous et tous
ces grands week-ends on va boire à 200 à
300 ça s'arrête et bien du coup le lien
social est rompu de ce côté-là et
c'en est au point que beaucoup de jeunes
coréens simplement ont pris une année
césure parce que pour eux l'université
sans la beuverie c'est pas l'université
une des autres conséquences de cette
pandémie c'est sur le travail avec des
impacts et économique
il ya des statistiques qui sont sortis
notamment sur les jeunes femmes entre 20
et 39 ans qui sont aujourd'hui
considérés comme un groupe à risque en
ce qui concerne les suicides en cours en
hôtel a été plus impacté que les autres
par cette pandémie en termes de travail
notamment
alors par contre oui ça le tutti sida
augmente et plus chez les femmes
par contre vous faire attention en corée
c'est comme en france les hommes se
suicident beaucoup plus que les femmes
vous avez à peu près deux hommes et demi
pour une femme qui selon elle était
plutôt épargné entre guillemets par ce
fléau est désormais elles le sont aussi
c'est ça et ce qui se dit ce qui se
passe chez chez ces jeunes femmes c'est
que vous savez dans les cultures
asiatiques
vous avez quand même une réserve plus
grande qui a tendu des femmes
et quand vous avez ces occasions de
socialisation forcé qui n'ont plus cours
pour toutes les personnalités un peu
plus introverti et c'est souvent aucun
des femmes à cause de la manière dont
elles sont éduqués dans des pays
confucéen ça devient beaucoup plus dur
que vous savez des gens qui arriveront
toujours à trouver des amis où qu'ils
aillent les faits isolant il est
beaucoup plus fort chez tous les gens
qui sont un peu plus discret et ça ça
concerne particulièrement les femmes
alors il ya des solutions qui sont
trouvées pour essayer de combattre ce
stress avec toujours ce côté très
théâtral de la culture sud coréenne je
propose qu'on regarde à un extrait avec
une cérémonie assez surprenante c'est un
il s'agit de
mise en scène de sa propre mort regardez
ce centre a été créé pour deux raisons
importantes
la société sud-coréenne prospère sur le
plan économique traverse une crise de
valeurs et la corée du sud fait ce
qu'elle peut pour la surmonter
les gens devraient comprendre qu'il ya
des choses importantes qu'on ne peut
ignorer les relations familiales ou avec
soi même
il faut le comprendre
avant de mourir nous donnons de l'espoir
et des forces aux gens qui pensent
sérieusement au suicide
le centre s'est fixé un objectif
beaucoup plus ambitieux que la seule
lutte contre le stress
les visiteurs sont invités à réfléchir à
quelque chose de simple la vie n'est pas
sans fin et cette dernière peut arriver
plus tôt qu'il n'y paraît
après une petite présentation les
visiteurs vont dans la salle de
funérailles
c'est une énorme salle où se trouvent
des dizaines de cercueils
les participants prennent place à côté
de leurs cercueils
ils revêtent détenus d'enterrement pose
une photo et écrivent une lettre d'adieu
[Musique]
et il ma chérie si je meurs je vous
pardonne moi ces mots je te demande de
ne pas te re marié continue de vivre
avec nos enfants comme tu l'a toujours
fait quand j'étais là
[Musique]
l'heure des funérailles approche tout le
monde s'allongent dans les cercueils qui
sont ensuite refermée les visiteurs
doivent passer un certain temps être
mort
[Musique]
le point culminant de la cérémonie est
la renaissance chacun sort de son
cercueil avec une nouvelle perception de
la vie et de la mort
[Musique]
des images assez surprenante qu'est ce
qu'elle vous évoque ces images de mise
en scène de sa propre mort où on rentre
même dans un cercueil
il ya plusieurs choses les deux grandes
choses que je vois là dedans c'est la
première vous avez un rapport à la mort
dans les cultures asiatiques qui est
très différent les enterrements dure
très longtemps et les enterrements là
encore son vous allez croire que je
présente la crue comme impies
d'alcooliques m'aider les enterrements
sont vraiment aussi des occasions de
bris léveillé les veillées nocturnes dur
réellement longtemps et il ya l'idée
vraiment de célébrer la vie quand on
quand on enterre quelqu'un est le
deuxième aspect qu'il faut voir c'est
aussi qu' il faut pas perdre de vue que
cette expérience c'est aussi une
expérience théâtrale
on joue sa propre mort ça serait pour le
dire comme dans les termes de jean
baudrillard
c'est un simulacre aussi de morts et
peut-être aussi vous savez c'est quelque
chose qui est un peu à la mode en corée
mais un peu comme on irait se tait
l'élastique par exemple l'idée c'est de
frôler la mort pour l'apprivoiser c'est
pas nécessairement quelque chose de
morbide et la troisième chose qu'on voit
et ce qui montre que les coréens sont
très conscients du danger de
l'individualisme qui se répandent une
société c'est que vous voyez ces
cérémonies
elle vise justement à resserrer les
liens avec les vivants donc on leur fait
écrire une lettre à leurs familles
c'est très important encore est parce
que le pays a changé tellement vite que
très souvent en fait la génération des
enfants et la génération des parents
n'ont plus grand chose à se dire en fait
leur vision du monde est tellement
différentes que vous avez des vieux
parents qui se retrouvent
vous savez qu'ils sont saignés aux
quatre veines pour éduquer leurs enfants
mais qui ont des opinions un peu réac un
peu conservatrice et des jeunes enfants
en fait qu'ils arrivent plus à
communiquer avec leurs parents
c'est aussi ce qui est intéressant dans
ce rituel d'écrire une lettre c'est
aussi un
quelque chose pour resserrer les liens
dans la famille du lien les liens
familiaux
il ya aussi des extraits dans ce
documentaire qui montre que des jeunes
sud coréens notamment vont dans des
temples ou même dans des fosses prises
on voit ça un moment de rendre le
reportage en fait ce qu'ils cherchent
c'est une forme d'ennui c'est à dire que
à séoul il n'ya pas de temps pour pour
s'ennuyer
non on peut pas si ou le 6 ou le d'abord
sait ou ne dort jamais et c'est même un
problème parce que c'est inscrit même
par exemple sur les prix de l'immobilier
la raison pour laquelle le prix de
l'immobilier s'envolent à séoul
c'est parce que tout le monde veut vivre
à séoul les gens savent qu'en arrivant à
séoul
y ils vont souffrir que c'est un miroir
aux alouettes
mais en même temps c'est qu'ils peuvent
pas former empêcher
et vous savez c'est un phénomène c'est
un phénomène que que tocqueville
décrivait déjà 19e siècle avec les
migrations d'amérique
les gens savent et qui seraient déçues
par les migrations
mais il pouvait pas s'en empêcher par
rapport à la vie plus routinières qui
vivraient dans leur pays d'origine dans
leur campagne au fin fond de l'europe à
l'époque c'est c'est plus fort qu'eux
mais si quand vous venez à seoul séoul
est tellement excitante et le reste de
la corée est tellement comment dire
triste dans le sens où la jeunesse a
quitté en fait le reste du pays donc
c'est presque inévitable
on peut analyser intellectuellement
l'échec de ces gens qui viennent à séoul
et on sait qu'ils vont être malheureux à
leur place on ferait la même chose
merci beaucoup christophe godin d'avoir
pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
sociologue et enseignant en sciences
politiques à l'université de séoul une
ville dans laquelle vous vivez depuis
plus de 14 ans vous souhaite un peu de
calme donc dans cette ville qui ne dort
jamais je vous remercie d'avoir suivi
cette émission je rappelle que vous
pouvez
la retrouver également sur le site de rt
france pointe avait tout comme le
reportage que l'on a décrypté
aujourd'hui gundam stress à bientôt
[Musique]